the police investigation is ongoing a
team of forensic officers is searching
for clues at the crime scene a Muslim
community center in London that was
destroyed by fire who were the
perpetrators and was the attack racially
motivated as police suspect muna Ali was
a volunteer at the center she began
coming here as a child to learn Arabic
and get help with her homework now the
design student whose family is
originally from tanzania has come to
take pictures for the community
capturing the loss this place was with
was a second home and it's like you've
lost a part of home basically and and
yeah that's just what it is for most of
the community they think that it's
they've almost lost a part of home how
could this happen munna can't understand
how much well he'll could become the
scene of such a crime it's a
middle-class neighborhood over 200
languages are spoken on the streets here
the area has a reputation for peaceful
multicultural coexistence unite against
fascism is an anti fascist organization
hosting an event to promote solidarity
muna and her girlfriends have come to
take part a broad range of speakers from
churches parties and unions have come to
show their support one of them is Ahmed
Abbas
born in Mogadishu he and his family fled
the civil war in Somalia 20 years ago
Ahmed felt safe in London until now very
disgraceful event that has taken place
in our community
this is to continue than the
multiculturalism that UK is very much
advocated seen is that there is a need
of more import more exercise between the
different racial issues the organization
faith matters promotes interfaith
dialogue the group offers a hotline from
Muslims who have been the victims of
attacks since a radical Islamist
murdered a British soldier in london in
may the phone hasn't stopped ringing
name-calling on a street they will
receive targeted mail Twitter that is
specifically Islamophobic they'll report
that in we've also had reports from
mosques about graffiti windows broken
and then the more extreme elements which
is around incendiary devices thrown to
create some fires on the internet some
Twitter users have written that they
think immigrants should have their
windows smashed or should even be set on
fire at the other end of the spectrum
hate mongers like Anjem Choudary have
refused to condemn that Woolwich
murderer government have said that they
can to continue in the foreign policy
well you know I don't think that it's
helpful to condemn anybody I think that
you know if you if you look in
comparison with and Islamist radical
Omar Bakri who was deported to Lebanon
went so far as to welcome the attack on
the soldier who was murdered while
London was still in mourning members of
a mosque in the Brixton district in
south london are disgusted by comments
like those the mosque itself was also
targeted shortly after the brutal murder
police are still searching for the
perpetrators Omar Jimmy key the Imam
here for the last seven years believes
his mosque is at particular risk like
many members of his community Oh mark
converted to Islam from Christianity
they tried to enter the building and
they actually tried to break in via
through the lock here so it has really
damaged and the other side is where it
was completely broken off in a bit of a
place since then also the person when
they
they threw a rock a large walk through
this particular window it was completely
smashed Omar and other Muslims in
Brixton don't believe violence is the
right response to the attack retaliation
is not an option say most of them even
though the majority are against
stationing British troops in Muslim
countries well every day on the news you
will see you know you will see your
brothers and sisters dine and so forth
but then you want you good good you that
you'd want to aid them via pray our why
are you all why are even I don't know if
you can send them a being it clothes
food and so forth not not in that really
not that no no we don't get on going
down the route of violence this brings
more violence but Brixton is trying to
address the problem especially newly
converted young men who might be
emotionally unstable or have a troubled
personal history can be more prone to
radical Islamist violence the Brixton
mosque has already had to exclude some
potential members if we find the person
may have ideas that needs to be looked
at they will try to get off put to tryna
environment that time we can discuss
those matters openly right on and so
we'll put those things that needs to be
put on the table and discuss them in
light of Islam as we are Muslim and with
Islam it out you know very
straightforward guidelines regarding on
what are right what are wrong will the
muzzle hill community continue to be
able to live side by side together in
the future that's one of the questions
discussed at a solidarity event for the
center there's a sense of unity going
around in muzzle hill we've got people
actually traveling in and and people and
we even had like one of the local
schools send us cards from all the
different layer group sending us and you
know like hopefully everything will be
well and everything use it's really nice
yeah definitely the small London
neighborhood could become a model for
the entire British capital but it's up
to all Londoners to create a new sense
of unity in their multicultural City
you